Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonsoir.
(Guitare)
(Chante)
Les pieds nus, perdue dans la jungle,
Je te suivais juste avant la pluie.
Disparu comme un coup de flingue.
Un peu sonnée, je tombais du lit.
C’est comme ça toutes les nuits
Depuis que t’as disparu de ma vie.
Sur les toits de Paris,
C’est là que je finis mes nuits.
Du lundi au dimanche,
Mise à nu,
Mes jours sont des nuits blanches.
Mise à nu, là dans le désert
De nos amours, j’ai marché des heures.
J’ai rien vu malgré mes prières
Quelques vautours venus là par erreur,
Face au vent, j’ai si peur
Depuis que t’as déserté ma vie,
Je ressens la terreur.
Je ne sais plus très bien qui je suis.
Du lundi au dimanche,
Mise à nu,
Mes jours sont des nuits blanches.
Tous les avions sont passés sans me voir.
À l’horizon le ciel est noir.
Quand les histoires se terminent mal
et qu’on les ramasse,
il y a des silences et des souvenirs
qui laissent des traces.
Lentement, je refais surface,
Fin de l’hiver, une histoire qui s’efface.
Doucement je remplis l’espace
Quand je vois la mer,
je ne bois plus la tasse.
C’est comme ça que j’oublie
Que c’est toi qui m’as volé ma vie.
Quelquefois, je m’ennuie,
Alors je vais danser sous la pluie.
Du lundi au dimanche, mise à nu,
Mes jours sont des nuits blanches.
(Fin de la musique)
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
J’ai eu la chance de vivre
un grand bouleversement dans ma vie.
Celui de faire un album
qui a conquis le public,
qui m’a permis de vivre ma passion
et de ma passion.
J’ai fait des centaines de concerts,
voyagé, rencontré plein d’artistes.
Mes parents se sont longtemps demandé
ce qu’ils allaient faire de moi.
Et quand ils ont vu
que je faisais ce qui me plaisait
et que ça marchait, ça les a rassurés.
J’ai rencontré Jean-Louis Foulquier,
une grande figure
des médias musicaux en France.
Et pendant une interview, il m’a présentée
comme la petite-fille de Barbara.
Alors évidemment, Barbara, c'est la grande
dame de la chanson française.
J’ai beaucoup de respect
et d’admiration pour son travail,
mais pour autant,
je ne me reconnais pas dans sa musique,
ni dans la chanson française en général.
J’en ai écouté, bien sûr, mais
j’ai aussi écouté plein d’autres choses :
du jazz, du rock, de la soul,
de la musique africaine.
Le plus beau compliment
qu’on puisse me faire, c’est :
« Je n’écoute pas de chanson française,
mais ton album, oui. »
Et ça m’est même arrivé
venant d’artistes faisant de l’électro.
C’est ça qui me plaît
dans l’art en général,
c’est quand les artistes
dépassent leur style.
Par exemple, NTM.
C’est un groupe de rap.
Ils sont arrivés
à un stade de leur création,
où ils ont agrandi leur spectre.
Ils ont dépassé leurs codes.
Et à la fin, tout le monde écoutait
sans plus se soucier de l’étiquette.
Et justement, l’étiquette,
c’est quelque chose dont je commençais
à me sentir prisonnière.
J'avais posé mes bases.
J'avais eu de la reconnaissance,
évidemment, c'est très gratifiant.
Mais je commençais à sentir une pression
de la part des médias et du public
pour continuer ce grand héritage
de la chanson française.
Et j’ai commencé à m’inquiéter
pour mes futures créations.
Je ne voulais pas qu’on me dise
« Refais pareil »,
parce que je pense
que je n’en n’aurais pas été capable.
Et j’avais déjà envie d’aller ailleurs.
Donc, délibérément,
sur mon deuxième album,
je n’ai pas vraiment été
là où on m’attendait.
J’ai exploré d’autres climats sonores,
d’autres instrumentations,
avec par exemple des saxophones,
des instruments plus exotiques
comme le gamelan,
d’origine indonésienne.
Et mon besoin était :
plus de musique, moins de mots.
Une partie de mon public
n’est pas rentrée dans cet univers,
mais depuis quelques années, des gens
me disent qu’ils réécoutent cet album
et qu’il leur plaît beaucoup.
Ma méthode pour écrire des chansons,
c’est que je n’ai pas de méthode.
La plupart du temps, je ne sais pas
sur quelle tonalité j’évolue,
mais tout simplement, quand ça plaît
à mon oreille, je garde.
J’ai composé des mélodies plus vaporeuses,
comme sur ce morceau
qui s’appelle « Valparaiso ».
(Guitare)
(Chante) Là-bas,
l’air doux te berce.
Dessous le firmament,
les rues t’emmènent
vers des étages de ciels,
ciels.
(Fin de musique)
Alors évidemment, cet album,
c’était comme un laboratoire
où j'essayais des choses.
Mais ça m’a appris beaucoup de choses
sur la communion avec le public.
Et le pont, c’est vraiment
les paroles et la voix.
Et là, il y avait peut-être
trop de choses qui faisaient écran.
J’ai quand même fait une belle tournée
avec cet album.
Je suis même partie au Japon.
Et ça, c’est parfait
parce que j’adore voyager.
(Musique)(Chantonne)
(Fin de la musique)
Un jour, j’ai découvert un film
qui s’appelle « Orfeo negro ».
Dans ce film, on entend cette chanson :
« Manha de Carnaval ».
J’ai eu un coup de cœur tout de suite
et j’ai mis dans un coin de ma tête
l’idée d’en faire une reprise,
de faire un album de bossa un jour.
Un jour, je l’ai fait.
Alors, évidemment, je ne me prétends
pas du tout chanteuse de bossa.
Je me suis aventurée sur un territoire
que je ne connaissais pas.
Mais j’avais très envie
de me frotter à ces mélodies
qui sont vraiment magnifiques
et très exigeantes.
J'ai adoré être seulement interprète
et porter les mots de Nougaro,
de Pierre Barouh
avec qui j’ai eu le plaisir
de jouer sur scène.
Pierre Barouh, c’est lui qui a composé la
musique du film « Un homme et une femme »
avec le fameux
(chantonnant) « chabadabada chabadabada ».
Voilà, Pierre Barouh est avec nous.
Mais par dessus tout,
j’ai adoré interpréter
un morceau de Nino Ferrer qui s’appelle :
« La rua Madureira ».
(Musique)
(Chante)
Non, je n’oublierai jamais la baie de Rio,
la couleur du ciel le long du Corcovado,
la Rua Madureira,
la rue que tu habitais.
Je n’oublierai pas, pourtant,
je n’y suis jamais allé.
Non, je n’oublierai jamais
ce jour de juillet
où je t’ai connue,
où nous avons dû nous séparer.
Pour si peu de temps,
nous avons marché sous la pluie.
Je parlais d’amour
et toi, tu parlais de ton pays.
Non, je n’oublierai pas
la douceur de ton corps
dans le taxi qui
nous conduisait à l’aéroport.
Tu t’es retournée pour me sourire
avant de monter
dans une Caravelle
qui n’est jamais arrivée.
(Vocalises)
Non, je n’oublierai jamais
le jour où j’ai lu
ton nom mal écrit
parmi tant d’autres noms inconnus
sur la première page
d’un journal brésilien.
J’essayais de lire
et je n’y comprenais rien.
Non, je n’oublierai jamais.
(Fin de la musique)
(Applaudissements)
Merci.
Maintenant que j’avais « chabadabadé »
et « Rua Madureiré »,
qu’est-ce que j’allais faire ?
Je me suis lancée dans l’entrepreneuriat,
je suis devenue quelque chose
que je ne pensais jamais être,
une entrepreneuse.
J’ai monté mon label et contrairement
au titre de mon album « Ne rien faire »,
je n’ai pas rien fait du tout.
Si je devais résumer cette période,
ce serait comme apprendre
à danser sur du verglas.
Donc vous voyez.
Mais vraiment, j'avais envie d'être
en possession de mon travail.
Le moteur de cet album,
c’est un morceau très important pour moi
que j’ai écrit en hommage à ma mère
et qui s’appelle « Tu es partout ».
(Guitare)
(Chante)
Maman, Maman, quand je te disais,
je me sens à côté, à côté de la plaque.
Alors, tu me répondais :
Mais voyons, ma chérie, ma chérie,
il n’y a pas de plaque !
Tu es...
Depuis que tu es partie,
tu es partout.
Tu es...
Depuis que tu es partie,
tu es partout.
J’apprends cette leçon de la vie
et je la prends en beauté, en beauté,
comme une claque.
Cette peine,
elle fait tant de désordre.
Je ne sais où la ranger, où la ranger,
il n’y a pas de planque.
Tu es...
Depuis que tu es partie,
tu es partout.
Tu es...
Depuis que tu es partie,
tu es partout.
J’apprends cette leçon de la vie
et je la prends en beauté, en beauté,
comme une claque.
Diamant, tu continues de briller,
de m’irradier en secret, en secret.
Tu es...
Depuis que tu es partie,
tu es partout.
Tu es...
Depuis que tu es partie,
partout.
(Fin de la musique)
(Applaudissements)
Aujourd’hui, ma musique évolue
entre chanson et pop urbaine.
Comme je l’ai dit,
je ne revendique pas spécialement
de faire de la chanson française.
Je revendique les paradoxes.
Je revendique d’aller
vers des sons plus actuels
en les intégrant à mes compositions.
Je me fais confiance en me disant
qu’à partir du moment où l’air,
la mélodie, viennent de moi,
c’est du Pauline Croze quoi qu’il arrive.
Donc, mon moteur, c’est de me surprendre.
Même dans les textes,
je suis partie chercher ailleurs.
Je me suis scannée, évidemment, mais j’ai
aussi voulu scanner mon environnement,
par exemple en parlant de personnages
du paysage médiatique comme Kim Jong-Un.
Avec ce personnage,
j’ai réussi à explorer un ton décalé
et en même temps profond.
J’ai aussi abordé des faits d’actualité
en parlant des phobies et des philies
parce que ça me permet de faire le
meilleur portrait-robot de notre société.
En résumé,
j’adore partir et ne pas savoir
où je vais arriver.
Donc, je suis très curieuse de savoir ce
qui m'attend et si le public va me suivre.
(Guitare)
(Chante)
Et voilà, le monde est phobe,
J’entends le combat de fauves,
Je creuse un trou dans la terre molle,
Planque mes conserves de love.
Et voilà, le monde est phile.
Excité comme une pile,
brûlant d’envie avec ardeur,
Pour oublier ce qui nous fait peur.
Et voilà, le monde est snob
où tu adhères et tu fais bloc.
Pas de nuance et plus de gris.
Pas de bémol, rien que du bruit.
Putain, la planète est folle,
des forêts brûlent et on somnole
en regardant cramer la faune
sur nos écrans de téléphone.
Démêler le vrai du faux.
Parier sur ce qui est beau.
Doubler la mise.
Tripler la mise.
Please.
Et moi aussi, je suis phile.
J’adore le son, j’aime le style.
J’aime le pain, mais pas la mie.
J’aime le vin, mais pas la lie.
Et moi aussi je suis phobe,
peur des sirènes et des cyclopes,
des jours sans fin où l’horizon
s’arrête au bout de mon balcon.
Démêler le vrai du faux.
Parier sur ce qui est plus haut.
Doubler la mise.
Tripler la mise.
Please.
Attirée par l’odeur des routes,
on me dit folle, mais j’ai des doutes.
J’ai des pulsions et des manies,
des répulsions, des empathies.
Soit tu es phile, soit tu te casses.
Tu joues ta vie à phile ou passe.
Où l’on t’efface et l’on t’épie
à coups de rasoir sur le fil.
(Fin de la musique)
(Applaudissements)
Merci beaucoup.